it's everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel wet today after waiting a
full month for my visa to be approved I
am finally talking about my new job and
absolutely none of you managed to guess
what it is
not a single one you know I'm really
surprised because I thought it was super
obvious but obviously like I couldn't
comfortably publicly confirm it until
all my B's stuff was organized because
that's like a super complicated process
and it could have gone wrong and the
company was like I'm comfortable with me
doing that but wow man no no view I am
going to fun house and I'm very excited
about it this is a weird video to make
because I feel like I have to make it
for people who don't know who I am but
know what fun house is and maybe want to
know what I'd be doing there or like who
I am or what I'm about but then also
half of people who are like well what is
that name what specifically is fun about
it is a lot is it a literal house what
do they do there so let's start first
with the people who don't know what fun
house is fun house is a comedy centric
gaming channel slash brand when I'm gone
and hung out with them we've made videos
like this is this a reboot of God of War
or is this kind of war v is this
assassins creed technically a reboot but
it's also set off dough so it neva and
also this why is this in this hotel it's
a dentist hotel like Disney themed
hotels it's like oh you know have a Star
Wars character bringing you your
breakfast this is like dentists they
call it the hotel mole are come on and
they have podcasts and shows and all
this cool stuff
I'm going there to be a content creator
slash producer which I already have a
lot of experience in but that is
ultimately means that I will be there to
come up with and help the team execute
ideas and sort of help them grow the
stuff that they're already very good at
which I'm really excited about of course
you will also see my face on stuff but
that's not like the main part of my job
which was basically the same as stuff
was for me at IGN is like yes I will
still be on camera but that won't be
most of what I'm doing during the day
I'm really excited about it
the stuff they do I like that brand of
humor and ultimately I'm really excited
to be working with a way smaller team I
already have a bunch of ideas of stuff
that I've spoken to them about so you
know let's stop making stuff obviously
not every idea that I have is going to
come to life because there are you know
business pipelines and and management
descendent budgets and all that stuff
but I feel like they are more open to at
least hearing ideas than literally any
other company I've ever worked at so
that is really cool so why this
specifically often I've mentioned this
in like every video where I've spoken
about leaving IGN but honestly I just
feel like there's a ton of opportunity
for me at funhaus and even under the
roosterteeth brand that I just didn't
have before even stuff that I didn't
have the opportunity to do as part of
media and I'll be honest that part of
this decision is that I noticed a
decline in games media like you know big
companies that have been around for a
really long time in games me struggling
to get as many views as channels like
funhouse do on individual videos from my
perspective as a young a person who does
also have a youtube channel that could
almost be a little bit frustrating and
then it's like I really followed the
interest in my career I want to move
with the direction the industry is
heading in and I think that is a lot of
personality based content and streaming
and all of that stuff and I just feel
like some of the older media hasn't kept
up with how the industry is evolving and
how the consumption of gaming content is
evolving and you know I want to be
smarter about that I guess I just felt
like a good time for me to make that and
move and I feel like by doing this I am
growing in the same direction the
industry is growing in so I want to be
super clear I'm still planning to write
the games industry isn't going to lose
me as a writer but even outside about I
just want to be making more creative
personality driven content I actually
pitched
piloted produced video edited beyond
plays on IGN that happened before I was
even in talks with funhouse but it was
basically just a series for a group of
personalities on IGN well you know I
would pick what game we would play I
would pick what date it would go up what
day we would record I would edit the
whole thing entirely myself and I would
like
thumbnails and do all of that stuff and
I really really enjoyed doing that it
ultimately didn't walk on IGN because I
Jan's audience doesn't care about
personality and that content was so
inconsistent with everything else that
IGN made but I think as soon as I had
done that I was like man I could do this
full time and have the journalism side
of stuff be a thing that I do in my
spare time and I think that both of
those things would be better as a result
of me giving it up that way so for
people who might know fun house but
don't know me I'm Alanna I'm a 24 year
old Australian who's been living in
America for like three and a half years
now and I've spent the last seven years
of my life working in games in some
capacity but I've also played games
since I was 3 years old only I mention
that because there was a commenter on
front house one time I was like oh I
know Alanna is more of a journalist than
a gamer but it'd be cool if she could
work with fun house and I was like wait
what wait what does that even mean no I
am a giant gamer but I did also start a
comedy podcast earlier this year and I
also have some skits on this channel
and although Let's Plays that I made on
IGN were very comedy focused so that's
the thing that I've been doing for a
very long time to just combined with
studying journalism and working for
multiple entertainment outlets I think
I've no amount of companies I've worked
for now is gonna be like 40 or so but
that also includes companies where I had
to pitch and then produce video content
so I feel like um fine house kind of
fits all of the skill sets that I have
like like a glove I hope it all goes
down that way and I hope you'll be happy
to see me there join me won't you and I
think that's everything for everyone who
wants to check out their content you can
find them on youtube.com slash Finance
I'll leave a link in the description
below let me know if you guys have any
questions of course I hope that you are
as stoked about this as I am
oh my light just went out what an
excellent time to end the video
alrighty you guys I'm Alana and I will
see you guys next time bye